we have some breaking news coming in few
in the last few minutes Iranian state
television has reported that at least 35
people have been killed in a stampede at
the funeral procession of the Iranian
general Qasem Soleimani hundreds of
thousands of people have gathered in the
town of coeur Mon general Soleimani is
laid to rest he was killed by a u.s.
airstrike in the Iraqi capital Baghdad
last week and the fallout of general
Soleimani killing has raised tensions in
the region his assassination has caused
an outpouring of public grief and anger
against the US Iran says it'll seek
revenge for the killing revered in life
martyred in death hundreds of thousands
of mourners witnessed the return of
general Qasim Salah Manny's body to his
hometown of care man after a three-day
state funeral procession across the
country this is where his journey ends
solemn Annie was killed in a US drone
strike in neighboring Iraq on Friday his
death is not only provoked an outpouring
of grief across the region but also
anger we repeat once again our willpower
is firm we tell our enemies that we will
retaliate but if they take another
action we will set ablaze the places
that they like and feel passionate about
the u.s. is already bracing itself a
retaliation paratroopers from the u.s.
82nd Airborne Division are on their way
to the Middle East they'll make up part
of the 3,000 additional troops being
sent to the region but tensions with
Iran have also thrown the US military
presence in Iraq into question there was
confusion after elite letter from the US
Defense Department
appear to suggest an imminent withdrawal
of American troops from Iraq it bore the
name of u.s. Marine general william
sealy but it wasn't signed the Pentagon
has since clarified saying the letter
was a draft and a mistake and there was
no decision whatsoever to leave Iraq
solemn Annie's death reigniting tensions
between this region and the United
States and for some analysis I'm now
joined by Natasha Lynch tej she's the
Middle East expert at Essex University
welcome firstly what is your assessment
of the fallout from general Soleimani is
death and the spike in tensions well I
think that has been pretty terrible
we're seeing that tensions between the
u.s. and Iraq have increased as the
Iraqi parliament had voted to expel US
troops there's all kinds of concerns as
what the US is going to do because now
they're trying to decide are they going
to completely leave how are they going
to manage this departure their concerns
that if they leave then there's going to
be insecurity in Iraq and the rise of
the Islamic state again and then of
course naturally the relationship
between Iran and the US just keeps
getting worse and worse we see Iran is
more committed than ever to pursue its
nuclear program there is absolutely no
incentive for them to to not do so
because from their standpoint what they
see happening is that the u.s. cannot be
trusted and to the u.s. is incredibly
dangerous
they basically assassinated the second
most important person in Iran so the
equivalent would possibly be if Iran had
taken out the Secretary of Defense in
the US or something to that equivalent
and so we're gonna see Iran taking
bolder action in fact they even said
they're not going to even use proxies
anymore whatever they decide to do is
going to be directly implicated directly
using their own military and so they're
going to take more such great
instability in the region now the US
meanwhile is sending in more troops into
the region does this mean that there is
a real danger
for military escalation there is a real
danger for military escalation because I
don't think that the US has a clear plan
about what the consequences would be of
this so many assassination in fact when
they put forward the idea towards from
the military apparatus didn't think that
they would actually that Trump would
actually make this decision and they're
not prepared as to what to do I think
that's why we see all of the chaos in in
the response whether they decided
they're going to leave the region or not
leave the region and then they're
deciding we're going to put more people
here what can only result is that this
is going to lead to an escalation of
recruitment of these militias the
militias are then going to go after US
troops and u.s. servicemen that's going
to lead to retaliation and I think in
the end not just we're gonna see a
higher military death toll but we're
gonna see a higher civilian death toll
as well Natasha Allen straight from
Essex University thank you very much for
that analysis thanks for having me now
Germany is announced that it's redrawing
part of its contingent of soldiers from
Iraq I'm now joined by our parliamentary
correspondent Thomas Farrow Thomas why
has the German government decided to
redraw some of its troops from Iraq
amrita we had access to a letter sent by
the german ministries of defense and
foreign affairs so german parliament
explaining the decision and the key
element there is security concerns that
german officials have in particular when
it comes to those soldiers that are
stationed in iraq it's important to
stress amrita that this is on a
temporary basis it's not on a permanent
basis and that we're only talking above
a small part of Germany's troops in Iraq
that they're going to be moving to two
neighboring countries in the region to
Jordan and Kuwait where again important
to stress Amrita that it is something
temporary Germany is particularly
concerned about the security on the one
hand as I just explained on the other
hand there are also concerns about the
political situation and how that will
evolve in the next few days and weeks in
particular when it comes to the anti is
coalition German officials have been
discussing this a lot here in Berlin and
in fact German Foreign Minister hi
mas had a lot to say on this this is
part of what he had to say on this
regard the fact is the troops who are
involved in a training mission for
example are no longer carrying it out
the coalition's entire anti ass combat
mission is also currently on hold so the
safety of our soldiers who are there is
our highest priority we're checking that
on a daily basis and have so far taken
every precaution to ensure the safety of
our soldiers on the ground so the
security as we heard from the foreign
minister of Germany of the soldiers is
most important and as you said Thomas a
German contingent in Iraq is small and
the withdrawal is temporary but what
message does this withdrawal sent at a
time of such high tension in the region
it is important to understand the bigger
picture here I'm Rita if you read
carefully that letter by German
officials it is clear that they have two
priorities in mind one is the stability
of Iraq something our German officials
particularly worried about and second
the ante is coalition which as you know
is a direct threat as well the is to the
UN and to Germany it's something that
German officials are particularly
concerned about as well is how they can
still continue to combat the Islamic
state in the region if the situation
continues to change in Iraq so these two
elements remain particularly important
for Germany and for the EU as a whole
and that's why German officials will
also be having various discussions not
only with Iraqi officials in fact
Germany is sending a high-ranking
delegation to Baghdad for consultations
but they're also having discussions with
other European leaders as well and let's
not forget that Angela Merkel herself
will be traveling to Russia at the
weekend to have discussions with that
emir putin there also on this issue so a
lot of talk a lot of discussions on this
issue that for Germany is becoming very
important indeed Thomas Paradis w's
political correspondent thank you very
much